foreign
Dr John has a PHD in higher education
and also a PhD in counseling and so
anytime those two intersect uh we really
get into a great discussion and he sent
me an article this morning and said
let's talk about this here on the air so
a hat tip to the guys at marginal
Revolution I love those guys
um so it's a paper from the National
Bureau of economic research
um
dinerstein and yanelis and Chin here's
here's the study so most people don't
know this but when it comes to student
loans there's
a little distill it down but there's two
different paths a college
this is a white paper a white paper this
is not an article on Yahoo finance from
Yahoo this is a research paper this is
actually a research paper by a nerd by
Egghead several several of my of my
nerds several of your nerd friends yes
okay um so
there's two separate paths one of the
paths is the government makes the loans
and the other is the bank makes the
loans and the government guarantees them
for the average borrower you're never
going to know which which one of these
paths your college took but when Biden I
think it was Biden maybe been Trump did
the first
um pause on student loan repayment
it instantly created a pretty cool uh
study that could be done because you had
a group of people Biden couldn't pause
the bank loans because he didn't have
the authority because it was the banks
that made the loans but it could pause
the
loans that the government made and so
these researchers came in and said what
was the what was what actually happened
there
and Dave I I used I was sending emails
to Dave this morning as I was going
through the math on this thing
at the end of the day they found that
the payment pause
helped for about 30 seconds
and the people who had to keep making
their loan payments did not have any
increase in defaults
they didn't have any increase in their
life falling apart the word I kept
coming to was or the words that kept
coming to us they figured it out
conversely those that were a beneficiary
of the pause
ended with more debt than they started
with
and I I just can't have to keep reading
that and reading that in a reading map
because Dave I remember uh Twitter tried
to set you on fire when you said that
thirteen thirteen hundred dollars isn't
going to change your life it's not or
600 isn't going to change your life and
what they're saying is actually that
pause made it worse
people took the money that was uh in
cash that they weren't sending student
loans and they went and put it on down
payments for more debt
so it would look like a great political
move it helped for a few months and then
it got bad so everyone's life is going
to fall apart because of covid and you
cannot afford to pay your student loans
so we the government are here to help
you we're going to put your student
loans on pause the net result is that
people took that pause and used it to go
further into debt
proving that they were not in much
trouble to start with
or that they had the capacity now to get
even more trouble exactly exactly
compare here's the note from the actual
white paper comparing borrowers whose
loans were frozen with borrowers whose
loans were not frozen due to differences
in whether the government owned the
loans we show that borrowers use the new
liquidity to increase borrowing on
credit cards mortgages and auto loans
rather than to avoid delinquencies so
the narrative was we are here to help
you poor people who have had your lives
destroyed by covid and you're not going
to have to make your payments because we
know you're starving to death and
everyone said hold my beer I'm gonna go
buy a car sweet now I need a car
sweet now I can get a car here here
that's exactly what the net result of
this is here's the line by the end of
the sample period student debt borrowers
have about five percent more household
debt
than the ones that did not get the
government help of the pause perhaps
paradoxically temporary student debt
relief leads to higher overall household
debt levels and larger future debt
burdens this is good news for debt
pauses as stimulus payments but bad news
if you think that debt pauses are just
the nudge people need to get their
financial house in order none of them
did statistically
they went further in the hole so once
again your government interferes in the
economy and once again they screwed it
up well I think this is a good moment
for me to say I was wrong
because I remember when when you said
it's not going to help save your life
and I thought to myself I think it will
I think it'll make a huge difference
and Dave in front of I'm glad you kept
that to yourself I did I did I would
have made fun of you I was a new
employee here
but I think it's fair to say I was wrong
man well I mean the the point it didn't
work the point is not a philosophical
uh let them eat cake statement when you
say thirteen hundred dollars doesn't
change your life but really I mean if
you are at the poverty level fifteen
thousand dollars a year thirteen hundred
dollars is not even ten percent of your
income
so mathematically the arithmetic says
thirteen hundred dollars if it changes
your life you really have already a
major screwed up life long before covid
came along yeah and it doesn't fix it
yeah you got some pretty Perfection it
is uh one more time the government's
saying they are doing something and that
was a different thing that was a Biden
bucks it was a 1300 that set they set
Dave Ramsey's on fire all over Effigies
all over us Reddit and everywhere else
and poor you know Dave Ramsey is just
one of those people that doesn't have
any compassion and you know whatever oh
crap it's just an obvious it's just an
obvious it's an observation of the
obviously not a college professor they
told me one time he said Mr Ramsey you
have a firm grasp on the obvious little
did he know I was going to make a living
doing that but yeah yeah so there you go
I do it all firm questions The Meta I
took away from this nerd paper and this
this just for y'all listening these kind
of nerd papers make my heart beat a
little bit faster I love them
um
I think this lesson is applicable to my
marriage it's applicable to raising kids
it's applicable to being a good neighbor
it's applicable to my finances there is
no such thing as I'll deal with it later
that doesn't exist it's a false premise
that I can kick a can down a road on any
issue in my life
um
like man pain deferred is pain Amplified
man and the more we kick stuff down the
road the bigger mess we are making and I
think it's an ethical issue when we are
a knowingly put putting hurting people
into more pain down the road or B we are
making our grandkids that we've never
met yet have to deal with this chaos man
it's just it's just unethical it's evil
debt ceiling race it's even here we go
again you know we're gonna do it again
let's just go further in depth because
uh none of those people voting on it are
ever going to pay any of it because
they're going to be dead zero they're
gonna be dead most of them are almost
dead now they're so old but yeah
unbelievable but yeah the uh it's crazy
so yeah that that it is unethical and
the thing though Dr uh
Les perrett our friend you know he we've
spoken with him a bunch of times he's
used he's been on Smart conference a
bunch of times and he always says you
know these negative emotions these
negative situations whatever they are
whether they're mathematical whether
they're relational whether it's a career
decision you kick the can down the road
this stuff has his famous phrase is it
has a high rate of Resurrection it will
be back it will I will be back yeah I'm
coming back and so you know don't let
the sun go down on your anger sit down
with your spouse and get this
straightened out it will be back you
can't sweep it on the rug it's not going
to go away it just gets bigger and
bigger and bigger that's that splinter
if you don't pull it will fester and
gangrene will set in we'll have to
amputate your whole arm because you
wouldn't pull this one little sliver of
wood out of your finger or you know
something scary your job is taken away
from you overnight tomorrow morning at 6
a.m you got to be on the phone finding
something else to do you got to be on
that computer to find another work you
got to figure it out and I hate saying
that because it sounds so callous but
it's me trying to tell you I love you
and I think you can figure it out well
step straight into the difficult thing
go run into the storm hard things yes
Michael Easter Comfort crisis do hard
things step straight into them it
changes your brain chemistry yeah what
Michael would say which I think is so
true is if you do hard things on the
regular as a part of your life if you're
constantly not running away from a
conversation you'd have with your wife
but you're leaning into it if you're
constantly stepping into challenging
moments with your kids constantly like
doing things like exercising and not
going for that extra dessert when
something like this hits your brain and
body are ready to run into the storm
you've tried you've been training them
right when you just take the stairs
right you're training your body and your
mind over time so that when hard things
hit bring it on let's go do this yeah
it's exactly right but if you've been
avoiding everything else and you get the
opportunity to avoid this
I'll kick the scan down the road see
those of you that are kicking your
student loan can down the road right now
and you're not dealing with it we're
talking to you for the last five minutes
it is coming for you this is not good
for you it's not good for you we've been
saying this a you owe the money and B
it's not going away until you pay it
this is the Ramsay show